good afternoon and welcome to the
McMillan Center everybody a Happy New
Year it's great to see you all here this
event today is it's a real uh pleasure
and privilege for me to be introducing
it uh I'm me and Shapiro I am the
director here um this this is part of a
large project that we have going at Yale
on the role of business in peace
negotiations we have uh research being
done on uh the role of business in the
South African uh peace process in 25
years ago um we have the work being done
on the role of business in Middle East
peace negotiations we have people who
have worked on what business did in the
northern Irish negotiations but today we
we are very privilege to have a panel on
um the role of business in the in the
Havana Accords and in most importantly
what comes next I'm here as a consumer
of knowledge not as an imparter of
knowledge today so uh it's it's I'm
about to turn things over uh to uh Maria
Victoria yente who uh is um the the
director of a very important Institute
in Colombia uh that is concerned with
coming up with ideas for the peace
process so
welcome
okay well thank you very much Professor
shapedo it's a real honor to be here and
uh I am supposed to introduce Mr Serio
Haro and I have been granted gred the
honor of introducing him before this
this
audience Serio Haro who has been the
High Commissioner of Peace in Colombia
for the past four years how did Mr
haramu a philosopher expert in Plato
became peace commissioner and more over
the essential actor of the most symbolic
and crucial peace process of Colombia of
the past three decades this didn't
happen by chance this didn't happen out
of the blues for the past 15 years he
has been working nonstop with an Impe
impeccable or better uh surreal sense of
beauty trying to bring lasting peace to
Colombia no more nor less there's like a
sound
here turn on the
computer turn that computer off
okay so in a first moment in the early
2000s as adviser of the Minister of
Defense he helped draft the policy of
democratic defense and security a pillar
of the highly celebrated Contra
Insurgency campaign promoted during the
government of president alvari in a
second Mo in a second moment Mr haramu
became Deputy minister of Def of Defense
being Juan Manuel
Santos now president of Colombia being
Minister of Defense as such he made
fundamental contributions to that
counterinsurgency campaign that ended
ended up bringing the far to that
negotiating table I would like to
highlight three of those contributions
the first one the strategy that led
hundreds of thousands of combatant to
demobilize individually crushing the
gorilla from within the second the
policy of territorial consolidation that
sought to build state in areas
historically dominated by the gorillas
applying the doctrine of integral action
and third the human rights policy of the
Colombian armed forces in the
understanding that legitimacy is their
greatest strength between these two
moments Mr Haro became was the head of
the think tank I now laid during this
periods during this period he
contributed to the understanding of the
Dynamics of the armed conflict in
Colombia and reflected on the central
role of business in peace building his
public trajectory has been Guided by his
almost obsessive conviction that the
ultimate goal is to consolidate the
authority of the state and the rule of
law throughout the national territory
the ultimate purpose is to integrate
Colombia that all Colombians regardless
of the part of the the country where
they live enjoy same the same rights
this is why the agreement with the farc
not only deals with their demobilization
and how they will be made accountable
before Justice for their for their
crimes a substantial part of the
agreement is devoted to address the
roots of the armed conflict to deepen
our democracy to solve drugs Pro the
drugs problem and develop and bring to
the 21st century the rural area areas in
Colombia
I hope Mr Haro that I have Faithfully
reflected your career path in search of
a stable and Lasting peace for our
country now I give you the
[Applause]
floor you hear
me is the sound
okay
well so thank you very much Mar Victoria
for those very kind words and thanks to
Professor for the invitation and to
anaria ianz and all the friends who are
in the
audience um don't know if Professor Owen
f is there um but I greet some hear from
about that I was asked to speak about
the challenges of
implementation and who would have
thought that precise esally the
challenges of implementation kept me
from traveling to a the president asked
me at the last minute to please stay
behind because we had a critical meeting
with the farc leadership yesterday out
where they're having uh uh a meeting to
turn themselves into a political party
we had a critical meeting to um sort out
a deadlock in the DDR process in the
movement of the far into contonment
areas uh and today we are voting in
Congress as we speak we are voting uh
the most important bill of the process
which is the transitional Justice
framework so when I'm done here I'll
have to rush back into Congress which is
where I came from I am extremely sorry
not to be with you especially as I've
never had the privilege of um being at
Yale but that is what life is like when
you are in the middle of a peace process
you become uh truly a late um I had
prepared some um longer remarks but
given that I'm not there with you I
thought that I'd keep them shorter and
leave more time uh for questions it down
now before I get to the challenges of
implementation I wanted to take the
opportunity to thank the US and in
particular the outgoing Administration
for all the support we've had in this
process we had huge support from
President Obama we had huge support from
secretary Perry who was extraordinary
active and responded to all our demands
and sent an excellent special boy Bernie
Aron to work with us I sometimes wonder
when was the last time that the uh us
had success with a a bipartisan uh a
program supported with bipartisan
support to strengthen a country's
institutions strengthen its security
that then ended with a uh classic peace
verus to end a 50 year war and get a
Guerilla to hand over its weapons that
is actually what is happening in
Colombia so thank you uh America and I
want to use the opportunity as well to
um do a small PL year for a for a
strategy of Engagement which is what I
think that President Obama and secretary
Kerry have done when you have a very
long conflict like ours or Northern
Ireland or Israel Palestine uh naturally
as as you all know identities tend to
fossilize people see no way out and in
our case we had a war of 50 years uh but
I believe that if you are able to
identify a minimal basis of consensus
and that is actually what of shared
interests which is exactly what
president Santos did in
2010 uh you can actually turn a logic of
Confrontation into a logic of
cooperation uh which is what a peace
presid is about at least about
the the share go is not always possible
one can't be naive there are examples in
history recent history perhaps in
Vietnam have negotiation but I think you
should always have a try just last week
we had the German foreign minister
visiting and I took him out to one of
the cantonement areas where the f are
going to lay down their weapons and on
the plane flying there he
said about colia the fact that you're
finally achieving peace is the fact that
you are showing the world that you can
actually have success with peace
negotiation most people have actually
lost
saith in negotiations and negotiations
themselves engagement itself in genders
New
Opportunities U suddenly gos open
windows open what seemed possible then
seems possible later on who would have
thought um 3 years ago that the far
would agree to uh acknowledge and be
accountable for the war crimes that they
would uh agree to repair their own with
their own assets something that no
gorilla has ever done well that's what
that process has made possible now it
has not been easy uh it's been extremely
tough we've had uh we started after
about a year and a half of back handling
we we started 6 months of secret talks
in Havana in Cuba that ended with
a framework agreement that has been the
road map for the whole process and then
we had four more groing years of
negotiations but in the end we had a
result now tough as this were difficult
as they were they are nothing compared
to the difficulties of implementation of
the challenges of turning those pieces
of paper into something
real there are some obious
challenges you can imagine you never
have enough resources you don't never
have enough money you have serious
limitations in your administrative
capacity in your ability to U deliver
results on the ground I want to focus on
on three or
four uh major challenges and then up
with a word about the private sector
which is the theme of the panel now I
think the first challenge is to make
sure that you actually have a vision
that you know what you are trying to
achieve the answer might seem simple but
you what you're trying to achieve is
implement the agreement but that is
actually not so simple because they're
different interpretations and different
views but a few people in colia still
have a minimalist view of the peace
process they think that it's just the
DDR process is just about the fact
handing over its weapons we were just
having a good discussion in Congress
this morning with the political
opposition precisely about that we said
no it's not about that just or some
people have
excessively I would call it uh
technocratic view of what the peace is
about and implementation just you know
you reach some agreement inard and
Implement them but I think it's much
more than that we've always said that
DDR is obviously a necessary condition
for peace if the F don't lay down their
weapons and reintegrate into civilian
life obviously we don't have peace but
it's not a sufficient condition we
always thought that we had to change
what I would call the enabling
conditions on on the ground that allowed
the this conflict to last for so long
and that's what we did during the secret
phase we agreed to an agenda in that
framework agreement that aimed precisely
at changing those enabling conditions
and therefore we AG with the part to
about a very limited but very
substantial agenda that includes rural
development political participation the
issue of drugs especially the problem of
coc Fields the issue of DDR and
especially the the issue of
victims so the whole logic of this
process has been one about ending the
historic conflict of Colombia it's a
logic of non-repetition not simply logic
of agreeing to a de process with a
particular
group and it's even more than that I
think it's a Once in the lifetime
opportunity to change a certain path
that the country was in to create uh a
momentum that as Mar Victoria was saying
will promote forces that will help
Colombia integrate territorially and as
a society that will help us as a friend
of mine Jim Robinson from Harvard now at
um University of Chicago said reorganize
State Society relations in those
peripheral areas of the country that has
suffered the the conflict and the key
idea here which are been talking about
now for for a few years is what uh we've
been calling I've been calling the idea
of territorial peace sounds slightly
funny but what it means is not simply
that you have to make sure that your
implementation takes account of a
particular nature of each given region
especially in a country like Colombia
that is so incredibly
diverse um it means much more than that
it means that you have to have a vision
of peace that is truly bottom up and
that tries to change the vicious circle
of violence that the regions of the
country were immersed in into
a virtuous circle that leads to True
institutional
strengthening um and to protection of
people's rights which is in the end what
this whole peace process is about
because only strong institutions that
can challenge and mediate conflicts are
going to guarantee a Long and Lasting
peace
uh so that's a vision what you need to
do is to make sure that it's shared it's
a shared vision and that is a challenge
it's a challenge to make sure that
everyone reads from the sh from the same
sheet of music we sometimes have
problems even with the own government in
in having a shared understanding about
what is actually in the Havana
agreement now to make sure that you can
actually get that Vision going that it
means something you need to set up a
process and that is a second challenge
we have to really mobilize CI
citizenship around around peace and
mobilize it in a methodical and
organized way starting if you like in
the kind of spiral working with local
communities participatory planning
processes were you know what
might standard manner you don't simply
just go and tell people what has been
agreed you say okay this is what has
been agreed for example in on the issue
of um crop substitution but we're going
to work with you to establish a shared
vision of what this region of Colombia
is about uh a shared view of what the
priorities for this region are and we're
going to turn that into concrete plans
and we're going to do that together with
you and to the extent that one does that
and then can actually then deliver I am
convinced that you move into you move
from this viscious circle of violence
into a virtuous circle of institutional
strengthening because people see that
they they count that they have voice and
that they actually that the government
responds to their needs and that their
priorities are taken into account and
you build trust which is possibly the
most precious good in a peace building
process in those far off and pereral of
Columbia that for so long have seen
government agencies trying to do things
without much success but it's not just
about the local communities it's also
about opening spaces for example
regionally in the regional capitals and
get getting people that never talk to
each other businessmen that never talk
to certain social movements or NOS or
the church or universities to sit at at
one table and discuss the future of that
region and help with implementation I'll
go back to that when I talk about the
private sector and then nationally you
also need to find ways to build Bridges
it is possibly difficult in the US to
imagine the kind of imaginary Frontiers
that exist in the mind of
Colombians um I once gave a talk in
Chicago quite quite a long time ago
about five or six years ago and I said
look it's a little bit like if in the
mid 19th century somebody in New York
thought about the the West the wild west
I mean something on the other side of
the Rockies we don't know much about
what's going on there we just know it's
a mess that's a little bit how people in
Colombian cities think about their own
country and what you knew what you first
thing you need to do is for people see
the reality to go out there so part of
what we're doing in Practical terms is
to set up um programs whereby for
example students can participate in the
various peace building process
initiatives whether they have to do with
rural development of transitional
Justice mechanisms and so forth and and
actually be there on the ground and then
come fly back home and tell their family
what they actually saw U that is a way
of integrating the country as well now
the next challenge I won't say much
about but is exactly what I was dealing
with yesterday which is the issue of of
uh DDR because
traditionally uh armed groups in
Colombia have reintegrated in Colombian
cities and Colombia has a strong the
government has a strong institution that
does that but in this case
the far that are a you know famously
rural organization want to the
reintegration in those rural areas and
they want to do it in a more associative
manner by putting together various
cooperatives that will guarantee them
guarantee them um a
living um and also an orderly transition
into civilian life and that is a big
challenge but at the same time can be
turned into a kind of win-win situation
if you if you get things as we've tried
in this speace process in a slightly in
a kind of clockwork manage to Dove tail
to each other so that in the to the
extent that you implement the agreements
uh we have on Rural
Development uh and on CR substitution
alternative development you create
opportunities for reintegration but at
the same time to the extent that the far
gets themselves organized uh with these
cooperatives they can actually
themselves
promote the implementation of those
agreements so it's a kind of win-win
thing if you actually get the right um
um structure to Dove tail the next big
challenge which would be a whole chapter
I won't say much about I have still a
standing invitation very kind invitation
from the Yale law school to go and talk
about transitional Justice which I
haven't managed to do because I never as
you see can never get out of either
Columbia or Cuba but the next challenge
naturally is is a great issue of
transitional Justice which was a massive
challenge in the negotiation it was a
true case of square in the circle you
are negotiating with the people who are
most responsible for the crimes
committed uh during the conflict at
least in terms of
hierarchy and you have to convince them
to set up a system of accountability for
those crimes that's what we had to do
and it was extremely difficult we did it
by putting together what we called a
inter or comprehensive system of
transitional Justice with a special
tribunal with a truth commission with
reparation measures with a special unit
to look after that has
appeared um and I can talk more about
that during the questions if you're
interested what I wanted to mention now
the immediate
challenge the real world challenge now
is how to coordinate that transitional
justice system with the DDR
process uh this has been very very diff
diffult because Colombia this is a very
very legalistic country uh in Colombia
this has become the major issue and also
for the far so they said well we do this
if we know what the conditions are so
the first thing we we had to do after we
finally finished the agreement was pass
a bill that grants amnesty for minor
crimes uh and what we're now doing is
passing another bill to set up this
robust transition Justice structure with
a special tribunal to judge soal
International crimes CRI Against
Humanity war crimes and so forth and and
there's this interdependence between
that process of what you might call
Legal security and what actually happens
on the ground in the DDR process and
that has been really very very
challenging to coordinate that was one
of the things we were trying to do
yesterday and I will finish by
mentioning the issue of the
um the private
sector now in Colombia the private
sector historically has been active
on issues of
reintegration uh in the 2000s many many
tens of thousands of competence from the
paramilitary militias demobilized the
government set up a special agency to
look after the
reintegration and the the private sector
um um came forth and and helped but I
think what we're facing now is a
challenge of a different order of
magnitude as I said at the beginning is
not simply a DDR process it's a process
that aims at actually changing
conditions on the ground in Colombia
that's a great opportunity we have so we
think more strategically about what the
private sector can do and I will just
mention very briefly a few
things um the first is there there's a
fact in many of these peripheral areas
of Colombia some businesses oil
businesses gas businesses palm oil
businesses often are
institutionally even stronger than the
government that has has a weak
presence on the other hand if what
you're trying to do is to really
integrate the country to as we say in
Spanish
institutionalize the the country the
territory then that is not just an issue
of bringing socalled
institutions uh putting them on the
ground again as as if that were
something that you just do from the
capital you can't and that's what we
that's what I meant by this territorial
peace idea you also need to integrate
them economically there is no way you
can actually be successful with the uh
rural development program we agreed to
to if there are no markets to absorb
that production from those small farmers
you're hoping to support or from those
people that are trying to get out of uh
po cultivation so the role of the of the
private sector here is critical these
are things that governments are not good
at governments are not good at marketing
and that's something which should lead
to the private sector but we needs to
create a structure whereby the private
sector is um
appropriately uh coordinated ortic
related with those
initiatives on the issue of DDR second
issue which I already mentioned I said
that we have this idea with the far that
they can put together various kinds of
corporates for example small companies
to build to do small U Road works in
those peripheral areas or
Transportation or small agricultural
projects and that's something that can
be done but to be successful because
those kind of projects mostly fail they
need to have uh somebody from the
private sector take them by the hand and
walk them along the far said for example
they want to build uh I mentioned it
already a small company to do Road works
so why not get uh an engineering company
a serious engineering company to work
with them and to U walk them through the
steps as to how you can actually do that
that's one of the things we are
promoting then there is a great and very
difficult issue of Justice I mentioned
already because
this the comprehensive system we agree
to far for State agents as well for all
who have had a relation or or a degree
of responsibility in the crimes
committed during the conflict and that
includes civilians that includes
civilian individuals and sometimes also
private
companies the way we thought about this
is that we want create incentives for
those who have responsibility for those
crimes that are not the most serious
crimes to come forth to tell the truth
to help with reparations and by doing so
for example in the context of the truth
commission to build trust in those
regions to build better relations within
society and to build a a a basis for uh
all the programs we want to put into
place and the the private sector that
has a role to play and finally
um I think it's extremely important for
the private sector to exercise very
strong leadership if we are building
peace from the ground up if we are
building building peace with this
territorial model we need Business
Leaders especially in the region to help
build consensuses to help um create a
shared Vision as I said before now here
we have a very big challenge which is as
many of you may know we had our own uh
version of brexit when we lost a popular
referendum at the end of September by
60,000 votes out of a um almost a total
of almost 14 million it was about4 over
percentile but we still lost and that
meant that unlike in the case of
brexit uh the message was from those Le
of the of the no campaign that we should
go back to the negotiating table and
sold out a series of issues on which
they had uh views and criticisms and
that's what we did we were we struck
first that with representatives of the
no campaign and we listened very
carefully took note of all to improve
the agreement and then went back to
Havana and had very very intense
sessions with the fart and by the end of
November we had had a new version of the
agreement that was signed but the effect
the effect of the popular referendum as
happened in the UK and perhaps as has
happened if I may say so now in the US
with elections was to strength to deepen
the differences to strengthen identities
into camps the yes camp and the no camp
and we need to overcome that I used to
think that the precondition for
implementation was building a consensus
but are now changing my mind I think
that the what we need to do is promote
implementation get everyone involved and
by doing that start building a new
consensus in Colombian society and I
think the private sector has a critical
role in doing that thank you very much
and if you want I'm very happy to answer
um your
questions
okay okay
people
questions
hear me yes hello Mr my name is nataliaa
I'm originally from M and my question
for you is is could you elaborate on the
modifications you made um from the
version prior to October 2nd to the end
of November I understand that time is
limited but I would appreciate some high
level summary of what those changes look
like so it it broke up could you repeat
the question yeah s the question is if
you could briefly elaborate on the
differences between H the first Accord
and the second one
after the one that was endorsed on
November yes
okay um well first a few details uh few
more details about the process because
it was a peculiar thing I mean we really
were in a very difficult
situation
um it was a risk inherent to the idea of
a popular
referendum um some people say well you
were crazy to hold a popular referendum
to end the war you simply end a war
which sounds sensible but at the same
time given that there were major reforms
that been preached we always thought
that if you wanted to have a democratic
support for them you had to put them to
the
people now those who voted no at least
the the the leaders of that campaign
said no we're not against peace what we
have is a series of criticisms of the
agreement uh so the first thing we did
was to S sit with them through many many
hours at the ministry of the interior
for almost about a week nonstop and we
took notes of all the points and we
discuss them with them uh and we thought
that many of them were things that we
could possibly get the far to agree with
there were some structural things that
we couldn't change because an agreement
is in the end a package deal so for
example no gorilla has ever signed a
peace agreement um to be sent to prison
doesn't happen
with with with the system we have uh you
you pay if you committed a very serious
crime uh um you serve a sentence in
particular conditions you are not free
to go wherever you like you have to do a
series of reparations and so forth but
you don't do it in a prison so it's more
dignified and it serves the ends of the
peace process that is if you tell the
truth if you don't you are sent to
prison that is just one example but on
the whole uh
we we we thought quite a few things we
could work on back to the for and said
look um we lost the referendum or the
Cici side and we need to look at this
proposal seriously and that's what we
did and in the end we actually managed
to persuade the f um against what we
actually thought to agree to a very very
large percentage of those changes now
what did they involve which is the
question uh on the issues of rural
development they had to do mostly with
guarantees um some people thought the
language of the agreement was too
ambiguous some people thought that uh
private property was a risk uh we we
never thought that was the case but uh
we managed to put language in to give
enough guarantees that things will be
done according to the Constitution and
current law and so
forth um
on the issue
of uh transitional Justice things were
more difficult because there were many
objections to the idea of a special
tribunal and people wanted to see more
clearly what the relation would be
between that special tribunal that
jurisdiction and the ordinary Colombian
courts so we made there quite a few
changes to fine tune the relation
between the fr transitional Justice
institutions and program and the working
of the ordinary courts in Columbia and
that entailed many many changes also
with regard to what the forecasts do we
we were much more
precise and about the conditions under
which they're going to serve their
sentences um I mentioned at the very
beginning reparations we had General
language reparations the new agreement
the far committed in writing to repair
their own victims with their own
assets um on the issue of implementation
and
verification uh which is as you know
extremely important uh critical for the
success of a peace process we also
improved many things uh about how the
international verification system is
going to work what the relation the
various pieces are and in the end as I
said I think we managed to meet about by
our count about
95% of the concerns of those
representatives of the no
campaign okay we we have time for two
more questions
please I'll take that one there and I
don't know if it's easier for you to get
that over
there
hello um you this is a very successful
obviously uh piece process and will
become milestone for the future what are
the things about the process that you
think are the most transportable to
Future uh peace processes and what are
the obviously every is different in
every area is different but what are the
key things that you would recommend uh
that were the most successful to
bringing to the Future and uh solving
other you know longstanding pce
issues well than thank you very much
that is that is first of all a very
large question and and second of all one
that wants to one that wants to answer
with a big dose of
humility because we still have to see
how things work out here also we we made
a huge effort I made a big effort myself
as perhaps also Mar Victoria said for
not just now over the last six years
that I've been engaging with the peace
process but over the last 10 or 15 and
trying to grow lessons from other parts
of the world we also have the benefit of
having people who work seriously on
peace process in other countries to come
and advise us on a permanent basis I
would mention
especially U Jonathan Powell the former
Chief of Staff of Tony Blair who was
responsible for most of the northern
Island agreement was with us most of the
time who was a Salvador Gilla that
negotiated in uh 1990 was with us and
others believe from
so Etc so we try to do as much as we
could to learn from others what do we
think that
worked it's a long answer but quickly
told I think that a a critical piece was
the idea of
doing Secret negotiations to arrive at a
framework agreement so that everyone
knew what the peace process was about we
couldn't afford in
Colombia failure we had already three
major peace processes that had failed
one in the 1980s one in the early 9s and
a very traumatic one in the late '90s
early 2000s that ended in nothing so
president Santos understood that we
couldn't afford failure we had to be
very careful and go step by step and the
way to do that was first to use a back
Channel very intensely for about a year
and a half and then to sit with the Fark
in a safe house in Havana
and say okay this is our version of
Peace what is yours these are the things
we are willing to talk about because
they are related to the end of the
conflict we're not prepared to talk
about any any issue in the National
agenda to talk about these things and in
the end they agreed to that and the
president in September of 2012 gave a
major speech and surprised the whole
country with the fact that we had
already an agreement in our hands and
that this whole thing had not leaked
which is more or less miracle in
Columbia which is a a media crazy
country so I think this idea that you
first do uh uh you know so-called talks
about talks that everyone is clear about
what the person is going to be about and
then you launch it was was a major part
of the success um what are the things
what I mentioned I think the president
after we finished the pce the secret
talks put together or strengthened
considerably the the the negotiating
team brought in a former vice president
as as head of the
delegation a heavyweight politician a
brilliant manto
laki who was fabulous brought in a
former commander of the Armed Forces and
a former director of the police so that
the key and and a major representative
of business talking about the private
sector so that the major stakeholders
all felt that they were
represented uh at the negotiating table
and especially as a process developed
and we regard to the delicate issues of
ceasefires and weapons we created a
special subcommission to deal with those
issues were serving officers for the
first time ever serving officers of the
Colombian military and the police uh sat
and under our umbrella negotiated
with the far and that was also um a very
important pillar of the process and it's
given its stability and as a result of
that we agreed to a quite an original
mechanism to the the monitoring and
verification of the ceasefire which we
call the
tripartite monitoring and verification
mechanism where you have the farc
gorillas trained as monitors our own
officers Army and police offic officers
and the UN officers that come from most
countries in Latin America and some
European countries working together
doing joint monitoring on the ground
together living together the German
foreign minister that I mentioned a
while back uh was uh shocked and pleased
at the same time to see how after such a
bitter War you go into one of those
areas those zones where this joint
monitoring mechanism is working and you
find the
army officer wearing the same vest as
the UN officer as the gorilla all
working together so all those have been
become trust building uh mechanisms and
I could mention a a few more but I I
will stop with those one of the things
if I ever get out of this job I'll have
to sit down and do think about harder
about what made this
work
question um Hello thank you again so
much for taking the time to today uh my
name is Lauren Wyman I'm a master
student and it seems from your
presentation that you view the private
sector as kind of a tool to promote
economic integration and ultimately
peace building in rural areas and I'm
hoping to hear a little bit more about
how this could apply or not apply to
semi-autonomous indigenous and afro
communities so how would this work in
that
context I I didn't hear the last part
how that could apply or not apply to um
semi-autonomous indigenous reserves and
also AF Colombian oh yes okay good no
good question um we have the we have the
president of France Al visiting next
week and we're going to take himself
take well out to one of the zones and
precisely we picked one were there are
very very strong indigenous communities
no what we did there's a very uh moving
moment of the whole V process because
what the issue of participation was
always a serious issue and a difficult
issue to to deal with because we had to
guarantee citizens
participation but you cannot have too
many people at a negotiating table
otherwise you make no progress it's just
too difficult so what we did was to
organize a serious of conferences in
Colombia during the process so for each
point for example Rural Development with
the help of the UN and the
major public university in Columbia
University who will organize a major
conference where 1,500 people would
attend and make proposals that would
reach Havana we did that for each
point um in the case of victims we want
even much further we organize for
delegations of victims who travel to
Havana that's another that's another
point that I should have added to what
made this process work was taking
victims seriously and making them
participate and taking their interest
seriously but in the case of the uh afro
Colombians and the indigenous
communities they said no no no no no
that's not good enough for us we insist
that there has to be a special chapter
in the agreement about us turns out that
uh the indigenous communities in
Colombia and the afro Colombian
communities
probably have the strongest uh
constitutional rights in the Americans
there very very developed uh Juris
Prudence in Colombia to protect their
rights and they were quite worried about
what would happen so the very last day
of the negotiations in September when we
finished with the first version of the
agreement they all turned up in Havana
and they said no no no no you cannot
finish this negotiation without us so he
said okay let's it down but we only have
a day so we sat down with them and we
wrote up six or seven pages of what is
called the ethnic chapter of the
agreement where all the institutions
that exist today to deal with their
interests and issues uh are
used as kind of filters for all the
things we had agreed to and if we you
mix that with the fact that we are
committed to a bottom up peace building
uh process then I think that their
participation is more than guaranteed in
fact when we were explaining the uh
agreement to the Colombian people in
September and went out I myself went all
around the country and where I found
perhaps the strongest support apart uh
naturally from students and universities
was amongst the indigenous and afrian
communities I assist I went to a meeting
in cal southern Columbia were under a
single roof
there were 7,000 indigenous people
sitting there listening carefully trying
to understand what the agreement was
whether they would impinge their rights
and bring them peace and at the end they
said this is the most important meeting
we've ever had in in this place so um
we've had very strong support with from
them and we hope work very closely with
them now on the implementation
phe s you Maria thank you very much for
the presentation and for the generous
time that you have provided us the best
of luck with your conversations now with
the Congress and now we're going to move
to the private sector
panel thank you very much thank
you let me to say again very very
briefly I sorry I'm not to be with you
um uh but thank you thankor Shapiro and
I now I have to run back and see if we
get the the vote in Congress thank you
byebye so I'm going to very briefly
introduce the the private sector panel H
which is one of the main topics that
brings us here H and first I would like
to acknowledge professor shapedo and the
McMillan Center for organizing this this
event ER in Colombia we really need to
discuss ways to move forward the the
peace process was successful we have a
peace agreement but the country is under
a heavy political polarization and we
need to find ways H to work together as
a society so Colombia as Serio said has
faced a complex conflict since
1964 in 2006 we had the demobilization
of the paramilitary groups and in 2016
we just had the S the the the
mobilization or the signature of the
peace agreement with the
farc and although the end of the
conflict is nearby we have two lingering
threats that are still present the eln
which is another leftwing Gia groups is
still operating in the territory and
second the illegal coca production has
again expanded in many regions of
Colombia bringing as always violence
upon the
population the impact of the conflict
was immense the official number of
victims is around
8.3 million people while the number of
internally displaced people is around
7.4 million which is about 15% of the
Colombian
population and the challenges of
implementing the peace agreement are
significant so let me just give you some
figures before introducing the the the
panel so that you have in your mind when
we're doing the discussion ER for
example poverty rates in Colombia in
2015 were 20
7.8% with a very large rural urban Gap
in the urban areas it was 24% while in
the rural areas it was 40% and it's in
the rural areas where as Serio Haram
said the peace agreement is going to be
implemented the inequality of the
country is high and is pervasive the
gene coefficient today is
0.52 which is the highest in Latin
America which is one of the most unequal
regions of the world
in 2016 we were very happy with the
unemployment rate which was in the
15year lowest but it was
7.6% and half of the work force is still
in the informal sector and when we think
about the agreement being implemented in
the rural areas the rural areas of
Colombia have several problems they have
been dislocated from the productive
centers of the country and they have a
lot of Social and economic problems
access to land which is the main
productive input in the country is um
low only 4 42% of of the rural
population has access to land and most
of this access is completely informal so
half of the people that have access to
land do so under informal agreements
land property is highly concentrated so
the Gen coefficient for land is
0.89 H which means that the top 1% % of
the land owners concentrate 43% of the
total hectares of the country the rural
areas are a very poorly equipped for
productive activities we don't have we
have poor infrastructure low provision
of public goods and little access to
financial
capital and the Central and local
governments have been vastly ineffective
and unwilling and I really underscore
the unwilling to promote the
transformation of the Colombia's rural
areas
so the pre the pr process really
provides an interesting
opportunity ER but what we need to ask
ourselves whether the government and the
society is really willing to transform
this opportunity into better conditions
for millions of people in Colombia or
will we Face yet again a broken promises
as several times it has happened in the
country and it happened several times
during the 20th century so today what we
are going to discuss is what's going to
be the role of the private sector to
sport for these H Transformations we
have three very important ER leaders
from the private sector and from big
large important countries companies of
the conflict we have Carlos Enrique
Cavalier he is CEO of alaria which is
one of the largest Colombia's Dairy
Producers ER he combines an extensive
experience with the private sector with
experience on the public SE sectors he
has worked in the ministry of Justice in
the ministry of agiculture he has also
been a congressman and state legislature
of kundara he was Professor for seven
years in the School of Management of
University losandes and he has a ba
interestingly in anthropology and
sociology and an NPA from Harvard
University alaria is a dairy dairy
production firm which is 58 years old is
one of the largest of the
country ER and it has a strong presence
in rural areas in Colombia
and it works especially with small
medium and large producers of of
dairy it has a long tradition of
investing in Social programs especially
targeted to small farmers to to children
and to adolescents providing
scholarships for Rural underprivileged
children and lately and in addition it
has designed a program called MAA to
reach they ref farers in previously
conflict areas and connecting them to
the markets we also have Antonio Celia
Antonio Celia is the CEO of promas
promas again is a very important and
large company in Colombia it provides
supplies 50% of the natural gas in the
country H he's president is also of the
board of directors of of nutresa which
is the largest leading processed food
company in Colombia and is in the board
of director of several H companies he
has been very active ER creating and
being the president of the board of
directors of two important organizations
from the Civil Society one is
empresarios which is basically a company
that promotes ER programs to improve
public and private education in Colombia
and also he leads the private Council
for competitiveness which is a company
that seeks an association to promote the
dialogue between the public and private
sector in order to improve Colombia's
competitiveness he's an engineer from
warus poly Technic Institute of
Massachusetts and he has Graduate
Studies from MIT and won School of
Business promas is a holding energy
corporation that has 18 companies in
Colombia and Peru as I say it supplies
50% of the gas of the country it has
provides gas to 3.4 million households
and it serves households from all the
income Spectrum in Colombia in Colombia
gas supply is large 62% of the families
use gas and they also have a very
interesting Foundation that is called
the foundation promas that promotes
educational programs in the country with
a strong emphasis on measuring and doing
impact evaluation of of the results of
the program the foundation has received
several Awards and recognitions for its
social programs and they have two
important ER specific programs for peace
building the first one is a program for
promoting entrepreneurship of former EXC
combatants and a solar energy proog
project in former Fark
regions the third speaker is Sylvia scar
she is the CEO of the organization terel
which is a very large company that
provides oil and gas throughout the
country and it's the third largest
company in Colombia she has extensive
experience on the private sector but
also and very importantly so in the
public SE sector she worked in the
Ministry of Finance and in the ministry
of plan planning of the country so she's
able to to be in both worlds and that's
important she has a Bor bachelor's
degree in economics from University
loses in Colombia and studied
econometrics in nbon in Paris France and
she is one of the most important woman
leaders from the private sector in
Colombia thelis are one of the largest
Distributors of fuels in Colombia they
have operations in Peru Colombia Mexico
Ecuador and Dominican Republic and
Panama and they have service stations
all over the country so they have been
suffering the effects of conflict for
many many years ER they have a lot of
social programs as well aiming
specifically to peace building ER for
providing economic opportunities to
former EXC combatants they have an
employability program they have trade FS
for entrepreneurs for them to provide
their goods and to sell them Goods H and
investment in income generated
H programs also they have one
volunteering programs in which all the
people from terpel work with former ex
combatants to build School togethers and
to to help schools H move forward so we
have a high level panel basically what
we will do is that we will have a
discussion among ourselves for 10
minutes ER then we will have comments
from Mar Victoria jente and chrisell I
will introduce them later and uh then we
will have if we have time we will open
the discussion from the so the first
question that I would wanted to ask you
is
a I want you want you to briefly mention
the social programs that you have in
your companies I skip through them but I
think it's important for the public to
know which are the social programs that
you have that you work H to for peace
building and especially concentrating in
what Serio said because most of your
programs are based on urban areas a
hiring EXC combatants and working with
EXC combatants and this new peace
agreement poses a new challenge which is
how are we going to incorporate these
people given that these people are going
to be in the rural areas of of the
country so Sylvia why don't you start
and then we
go
yes okay thank you very much thank you
for be here at this time and and we we
we are very excited to be here and be
telling you all about what
doing did she hit a button she turned
everything off she did well once you hit
that it kills everything no
problem so I was telling you
about what what we are doing now and
more important than that what we are
thinking that that we have to
do um an Maria asked me to to tell you
about the programs we had before the
peace agreement we used to only have and
this is I have to say thanks to Maria
Victoria and all the work that she's
been doing with the foundation because
we changed a lot what we thought about
our social ER importance after the peace
treaty so beforehand we worked in
education and we still working in it and
we believe that education is the most
important thing that anyone can do in
Colombia to really change the conditions
and to really H change what the future
will be for our country however ER we
decided that we were going to separate a
new program and we called it
reinstalling dreams and reinstalling
dreams because I really think that in
Colombia ER we stop thinking about a
good future we stopped trusting that we
could do a better country while we were
in this 50-year war with the park and it
so this this new treaty has has brought
to our country like the possibility to
think ourselves in the future which was
something that what we lost for many
years so that is why we call
reinstalling dreams and in this
reinstalling dreams we have what Ana
Maria mentioned about employability and
about procurement procurement was the
second thing we did after just receiving
people that were a getting out not only
of the Gila groups but also paramilitary
groups so we received all these people
and then we thought that it was not only
employability that was important but a
the the that people could have the
opportunity to make their own companies
and be our provider so that was the
second thing that we decided to do but
more than that and what I told you about
the future is that we think that we have
to share our knowledge and the things
that we do with these rural sectors and
these territories that we have all
around
Colombia as an Maria mentioned
also we are in I don't know
95% of the municipalities in in in
Colombia so we really are making a
presence in in in all the territory
which is very complex in Colombia so
what we are deciding to do and this we
are not doing still is participating in
civil societies um building like a small
places where we can teach people ER lots
of things that we that we know as I
don't know how to employ someone how H
to work in Excel how to things that are
very very simple but are very necessary
to reinstall a new way of living so that
is that is like the the part of re
reinstalling the part of participating
is very important in
Colombia um all I no I wouldn't say all
but most of the companies private sector
companies do not participate they never
participate in a like social spaces and
participation spaces we think that that
is I don't know for communist and for
indigenous and for yeah and that is
really something that we have to change
because if we don't participate in the
social a spaces they will be Tak by
other people and it's very important
that we defend productivity and that we
defend everything that democracy have
stand for for many years in Colombia ER
I think we will have more time to speak
now H so so I will tell anonio
and my
friend my friend my
boss thank you thank you very much for
the invitation I'm very glad to to be
here uh I I uh have to say that the
reason uh why we are here is that
because we believe in this process I
think it's the first time I have to say
because uh with the polarization that we
have in the country uh not all the
entrepreneurs are being supporting the
process in Colombia uh Carlo Cavalier
syia Ki uh we have been uh supporting
promoting and talking about the benefits
of the peace process in
Colombia uh we suffer very much in our
case just to give you an idea of the
context uh we own close to 3,000 kilomet
of pipeline all over the country we had
26 bomb attacks between 1997 and
2002 uh so we cannot
forget that's one simple example of infr
structure being attacked by guerillas
both eln and
far uh sometimes memory is short and we
tend to forget what happened in the past
in Colombia we suffered people suffer
too much especially in rural
areas and uh we helping again because we
do believe in this and we are conducting
at the moment two uh projects one in
solidad atlantico this is
a
um location near barania the city where
we have our headquarters with all type
of social difficulties all type of
social difficulties uh what we doing
there is we are are working with the
reintegration agency of
Colombia and we pick 200 people former X
former Park and we're teaching them to
develop their own uh
micro
companies uh we working initially with
uh psychological
support uh and all what is required uh
for a person that been in the Gilla for
many
years uh these are 200 uh pilot or
person we're trying with to see whether
we can develop a productive
Enterprises
uh the first thing that we they have to
learn is this is to make
money this is very important uh and I
want to remark here the importance of
the private sector the private
investment because market economy is
winning market economy is the way even
though we have inequalities we have to
reduce them through taxes or through
social uh investment
but they have to be sustainable so we
have to make money with the companies
that we creating uh we began one year
ago so far results are very good they
are in a very positive attitude and
hopefully that will work and the second
one is uh uh we are working perhaps in
the worst area in Colombia Maria uh Koto
Kaa Kaa is been the center of all type
of conflicts for 150 years there gas
paramilitar drugs uh uh all Ty all type
of problems and what we're trying to do
is to make money again make money in a
decent manner make this is not social
assistance this is not philanthropy we
do that in our foundation but is to
learn and teach how to make money with
solar panels in the houses in Coto Kaa
in association with
far we are
developing installing the first uh
panels uh these are not connected areas
with electricity 600 small towns in
Colombia do not have electricity Service
uh many of them or some of them are in
this area of ccan Coto so we're trying
to have a kind of a joint venture with
to inar and our company in that area to
develop solar energy systems all all
over these small towns when I told this
to profet Shapiro some months ago that
we met in kahena he told me are you
would you be willing to associate with F
I said
yes uh we're trying to see whether we
can do we can do this and the other uh
work that we're developing uh this is
through Foundation proas is uh we're
very concerned with education uh
education in my opinion is everything
Latin America is behind except for Chile
in all the uh indexes of Education
especially in Pisa which is like the
main indicator of quality of Education
in the world colia went up to notches in
the last uh in the last the last pie of
uh test however dispersion is huge and
there is a enormous difference between
rural education and urban education and
public education and private education
here you have private Urban education
and here you have rural public education
we are making uh emphasis in improving
rural education in uh 128 communities to
rise their level uh we already have uh
proven
results and uh education takes time and
the time of the of Education timing is
different to political timing that's why
social uh uh Civil Society has to be
pushing all the time and uh requesting
uh the local uh government to provide
good
education
um and then I I think that one of the
challenges that uh we have besides all
these progams uh in which we were
involved and and I think that that they
will help uh not for its size itself
because they're not this these are not
big progs however they they could become
big because these are pilot plans is for
the uh demonstration effect is uh the
message is we can show you how we can
make money if together better and and
sustain a project of life and have a
better future but the big challenge in
my opinion here is that we have to help
to build a more effective State a more
effective state that has presence in all
rural areas and have the real Monopoly
of Law and Order uh one of the reasons
of guerillas in Colombia according to
experts is the absence of State in all
its manifestation so we have the
challenge of make it more
effective uh to that matter there is a
very interesting document published by
corpor I don't know if you know it maybe
you know you know everything all
theem uh the title is how to build a
more effective St and that's a
challenge uh not only for Colombia but
especially for Colombia but for Latin
America in general with certain
exceptions and again if the
implementation will be successful if we
are able to build a more effective State
effective state is that that not only
design the public policy but implements
efficiently the public policy and learn
in that process I think that's why the
private sector has a very important role
to play here and again remarking the
importance of the private investor for
economic growth which is very very
important
um oh here here
sorry um Antonio is also my boss is U we
work together in the foundation for uh
entrepreneurship and that's what we used
to do before uh we did education work uh
with rural children uh to aerate uh
their col ATS and get into college uh on
their privileged children and uh to mate
the conditions of schools in towns
uh so the overall system of Education
gets better in the second instance we do
a lot of work at fot Banks as we have a
lot of returns from milk that we used to
uh uh used in the business to feed uh
all the cows and now uh we can give it
to food
banks um and they use it in perfect
conditions for people who are uh
undernourished and in
low-income um groups in in cities
especially children and elderly um our
work um with uh the peace process came
after a suggestion from uh
seru uh in a meeting was uh held about
nine years ago he just left the ministry
the vice Ministry of justice of
of defense and he was trying to ask
companies to come and help with the
consolation area of
maena uh which is the area where the far
had been traditionally for there for 50
years uh and the government had taken
away militarily a lot of the area and
they needed um people to come in and or
companies to come in and help um
transform the economy which is really
was very much into
coka and uh there was a farmers we
produce 5 or 10,000 lers a day and we
came in in 2 years uh it became 60,00
60,000 L of uh uh uh a day of of milk
and we collected uh milk from, 1500
families that didn't have their milk
collected before or didn't produce that
milk um and the way that happened is
that uh let me regress a little I 3
years ago I was I was when I was a state
senator in Columbia we we organized a a
a trip to visit the park which is not um
was back then the this fire with uh
presid with dor uh a lot of people flew
into the helicopters and visit them and
talk to them uh we had to go by Dunkey
uh three days on the fora mountains uh
but it was a beautiful experience to see
with the
geography and this is a geography that
and how they live and how uh in the Fark
and the middle of the um andian
Mountains and the beginning of the
amazan
Jungle um and understand the livelihood
and and the places where they lived and
they where they camped out for so many
years um and then the uh year uh the
next year in 1988 I lost the election so
I was uh taking in um as a govern
employee at the minister of Agriculture
and I got to see the same region from
the government eyes
how um the government didn't work uh in
credit didn't work in seeds didn't work
in um technical assistance and uh that
become became a joke that we used to
understand that how Coes work because
the government didn't get the credit uh
didn't give the technical assistance
didn't um um guarantee the purchase of
the of crops but the but the um the the
kingpins of of drugs did did all those
things they gave them the the money they
give them the credit assistance they
give they guaranteed the purchase of the
of the of the coca leaves and the
business work beautifully so uh when Sur
invited us to come I said well I know
how this thing works you really have to
understand that uh you have to do
everything that has to be done there and
S he was saying that uh we are more uh
same happens with um Pras or terel we're
the state in some parts of those regions
um because nobody's organized over there
and we provide a lot of things that the
state doesn't and we understood that
early and that's how we grew so fast and
so many families and we um buy about 7
Millions uh 7 or8 million dollar a year
of milk into an area that
didn't have that amount of cash coming
in and out um and what happened uh what
we did was two very little things that
nobody did before we came in every day
with truck with tanks with uh truck
tanks and pick up the note and every two
weeks we send a
checkout and that never happened before
because uh everything happened in those
areas was informal so people came in for
the milk one day the other didn't come
the other day didn't come the third day
maybe they came the four day they they
came the fifth day they came late
seventh day didn't come and the payments
were the same sometimes they paid
sometimes they paid half the milk uh and
sometimes disappear with them with the
money from the farmers they owed so um
they were not really connected to the
urban economy and now they are
uh and for us was in a way simple
because there was uh uh militarily uh
controlled and we had some troubles here
and there but not mayor maor troubles
and uh we've been buying milk from
almost 10 years um and uh we had maybe
uh 10 days of trouble here and there uh
or routes that you can get out and um so
we we understood a lot of the process
that um happens and a lot of the ideas
that uh s was
mentioning um especially one that is
very critical about Colombia is that um
there are two Colombians the informal
one and the formal one and the uh for
the rural for the agriculture products
the rural areas the
um will start uh after the city um stops
and it's totally informal or almost
totally informal and the rules
informality that I just mentioned is how
they work so you go out 10 miles out of
Bot 20 miles out of B and there people
in poverty uh of the 40% that Maria was
talking about um and you see the city
and you come into the City and the city
is a city where it works uh sometimes is
a second world not third world uh they
have electricity they have um formal
transp
Wi-Fi um supermarkets and you got in
super to the town 20 M out and then you
find yourself with different Colombia
one of the best descriptions I've heard
of Colombia is that we're an archipelago
of cities in a sea of uh again taking
the words that said he using the wild
west what you enter the city and things
are safe uh they're modern they work
like anywhere else in the world world
and then you go out there and well now
it's safer but the rest of the things uh
are very much in the disorder that we've
known them for 150
years okay I I would like to ask another
very different question and is about the
strong political polarization that we
have in Country and this may weaken
significantly the peace process and the
implementation of the process and the
private sector has been historic ad to
assume
political you the three of you support
the peace process you said it publicly
but I would like to ask you
whether the private sector would be
willing to become a more vocal supporter
of the peace process we really need
additional leaders besides the
government and and the politicians that
have supported the process and the and
the private sector can really have a a
strong leadership role in this process
Christ is going to talk about that about
South Africa and I would like to hear
your thoughts on
that uh you're right I think that uh
that's very important
uh we we're part of uh half of
entrepreneurs I can I think that I
I yes of uh old entrepreneurs in
Colombia or the big entrepreneurs in
Colombia
half of them do not agree with this half
of us we are here and we do this on a
permanent bases not only here in
Colombia
everywhere uh let let me tell you two
things we
try and this is public now we try to
reach agreements between central
democratico and the
government we spend hours and hours and
hours hours trying to close the
gaps and at some moment in December 7
last
year we thought that we were very close
to reach an
agreement uh the idea behind that was a
simple concept of a fact
or basic Accords on fundamental issues
for the society even though you do not
agree in some other
matters but if you reach agreements on
basic things like security Justice
education uh I think that a society
could be better of and if we understand
that our adversary is not our enemy that
could help in in the the idea of trying
to to uh uh reach points of
encounter so we did uh uh a job on that
Anam Maria we
work uh
hardly uh at the end of the day I mean
there is a political consideration here
that is beyond
our understanding or rationality if you
can if rationality exist uh to determine
what is the right decision for the
country or not uh we have been publicly
uh um announcing or telling or speaking
louder our position and uh recently we
created the private Council for
sustainable peace uh this uh Council was
created two months
ago and uh with the um approval of the
government uh this is a group of
universities Association of
entrepreneurs and think tanks like uh uh
M Victoria
F we uh want to
um follow up the implementation process
in
Colombia and uh we're going to start our
meetings next week with a the postc
conflict uh Minister Rafael Paro and the
idea is that uh we have a lot of
knowledge I
think and uh
willingness to make the implementation
to do the implementation work well and I
think that's a very powerful message an
Maria in my opinion uh that a group of
uh private
institutions uh gets together with the
Colombian government to make sure that
implementation of the process work well
so I think this uh is the first time you
hear this name but I I hope you will be
hearing from it uh many times the
private Council for sustainable peace
with the acceptance again of Serio Haru
and the president Santos
himself I would add an Maria um
absolutely we are willing H to support
the peace process I absolutely believe
that forgiveness is something that is
absolutely necessary in Colombia
and uh there is uh this phrase that I I
love a lot is from this a priest that's
been working a lot in reconciliation and
he always says forgiveness does not
change the past but it absolutely
changes the future and uh we believe
that more than for forgiveness that we
have to do with the far and bitar and
all the kinds of of of people that we
have inside the government we need to
have that because as Antonio says this
is irrational I mean this is just
personal it it goes beyond any political
thing so a reconciliations got to happen
inside uh this
political two positions which are really
just personal right now and um and that
b and as Antonio says we are going to
support absolutely the the council and
and are willing to have great results
from
that there's no question that we support
the process and we have to go way out i'
I've asked Minister Paro how many
hectares of the 2 100,000 can we taking
it for milk and do the ma process really
pilot and do lots of milk coming out of
our Farmers uh which shouldn't be too
difficult the question is um there was
an article uh by Fern sepa uh a few
weeks ago
and he was citing um a conversation that
Zan Li had with um Kissinger in the 70s
when he was trying to uh uh approach um
China and the United States and Sh Li
said we don't we don't understand you
Americans because politics is about
positions you're too pragmatic you just
get you know business here and there and
this is what happens in politics that
people take positions and the keep the
positions like military positions and uh
giving out positions doesn't seem very
normal for us because we uh in business
we need to have transactions uh for
bettering people's livelihoods so that's
kind of what happens in Colombia people
are taking positions on the government
side and on the Central democratical and
uh they become in aable positions so how
we we can make a role to that those
positions become less unle and less
fixed and uh we can understand U that we
have a can have a conversation our
processes I just want to add the success
of this uh private Council for
sustainable peace will depend on the
space or the yeah the space that we
receive from the from the local
government but again I think they have
to understand people in general have to
understand uh the importance of the of
the private sector uh because again we
need that the economy works well and uh
and everybody is do
better
to one of the
p colia on crime and guance issue
National and citizen security polies and
policy police reform she worked as an
associate researcher at
theom at the department of Economics we
were
neighbors did ba on political science
from the University loses CHR is a from
South Africa she is a a business and
program director of emba and inba right
now he's an assistant professor on
leadership in the N Ro
and he she he is visiting lecture at the
University of stos business school but
very importantly so and for our case in
Colombia and for the three of you during
the 1980s in South Africa he brought
together more than 100
CEOs and several hundred managers in
South Africa to form the consultative
business
movement and the purpose of this
movement was really to
unite Business Leaders around the
challenge of aart ha and work for a
democratic future for for South Africa
and so I think he can provide very
interesting comments experiences and
Lessons Learned for for us and for the
country so Maria why don't you go ahead
and D
please no yes
first sorry
yes good evening uh it it's an amazing
story that I've heard very very
inspiring
and I just want to pick out one or two
or a few of the the lessons that we
learned and also looking at it within
the context where it seems to me with
with inadequate information since Ian uh
invited me here I've been studying up on
on the challenges facing your country
and I see many similarities with South
Africa but I also see some some very
real differences the context of the
1980s in South Africa was that we we had
a very oppressive aparte government with
racist
legislation and we had a strong uh anti-
aarte movement but inside the country it
never achieved the type of military
impact that that I can see and hear
occurred in your country outside of the
country there was a a armed struggle but
uh it didn't have that real impact in
the country at that stage you had the
white dominating government or white
government on the one side and the
essentially Black Mass Democratic
movement anti apartate on the other side
and they didn't talk to one another and
so one of the insights was that perhaps
business could come in and play a role
and over a period of three years we
started out and this is part of the
lessons that we learned and it seems to
me some of the things that you've also
implemented we started out with um what
I would call change Mavericks I'm going
to use what I call the CMS of change
which we unpacked out of some of the the
lessons we learned the change Mavericks
to start off with were three or four
Business
Leaders one of them was charged by the
president uh with a presidential
commission of inquiry which led him to
be fired from his role and he was the
CEO of one of the top three banks in the
country so so there were certain
sacrifices but what happened is this
small group three four people uh started
slowly growing and over a period of
about a year we had 12
members uh it took that long because it
was and it was viewed as very very
antagonistic to to take a position and
and you mentioned that the issues around
position and what the mass Democratic
movement was saying to us is that if you
don't take a position we've got nothing
to talk to you about
if you want to be pragmatic forget it
out of that grew through uh
collaboration with the the mass
Democratic movement um which included
people in thec that were in Exile many
of the leaders were in hiding on the run
it meant that Business Leaders uh in
effect had to break the law in order to
meet with the representatives of the
mass Democratic movement after about two
years of this we met managed to get 40
Business Leaders and 40 representatives
of the mass Democratic movement into uh
one
room and there over a period of three
days we established a movement and I
think this is a very very vital thing
and when I hear you talking about the
private Council uh for sustainable peace
uh I hear bells ringing of a
movement and and I'd like to put
together two things that I've heard
coming from you number one is you've got
to take in a position number two is
you'd better have a
movement because the movement needs to
be able to grow so out of the the change
Mavericks we got what we called a
creative minority a very small group of
people but they were able to make their
voices heard and then suddenly going
from four people to 12 people 8 months
later we had
120 and 120 CEOs and they were all CEOs
this was one of the key issues around
membership of consultative movement
consultative business movement you had
to be the CEO of the company we targeted
the sort of top 500 companies So 20% of
the top 500 isn't bad we also were
looking at people whose voices could be
heard and would be heard and within a
year having achieved the 120 so uh
Business Leaders we then got to what we
call the critical mass uh at the peak we
had around about 500 Business Leaders uh
now ranging from corporates uh very
large the type of companies that you
represent through to mediumsized
businesses scattered throughout the
country there's one thing that I've got
to learn about Colombia that I frankly
don't have an answer for and that is
that South Africa's got a very
well-developed
infrastructure uh we have five to six
major urban areas cities but uh there
there are really good roads and really
good railway lines and and you can get
to places uh without donkeys uh so so I
think that's a very very big difference
uh in in your country and and ours is
that we were able to to have
connectivity there would be times when
in any given week there would have been
more than 5,000
uh managers meeting with equivalent
numbers of people from the mass
Democratic movement and this is for me
one of the most important lessons we got
people to know one another by
name relationships were created uh
people started seeing one another not as
the enemy but as someone who also had
concerns someone who also had children
someone who also had suffered uh and and
that to really built this network CBM
consultative business movement went on
to become the Secretariat for our
national
negotiations so when you bring 100 to
500 CEOs together uh several hundreds of
managers in that process one of the
things that business did and and I
haven't heard that but maybe that's
something that is also
occurring uh tens of thousands hundreds
of thousands of people inside business
particip ipated in dialogue
sessions where this is one of the things
of course in my country I don't know
yours well enough but business brings
together the community it brings
together the working class the
managerial class the the the uh the
lower paid people the highly paid people
it it is a small bit of the Melting Pot
and uh dozens and dozens of companies
use that in order to create uh dialogue
between black and white between
capitalist and socialist and and so a a
convergence grew out of that but let me
complete by
making comments that occurred in the
1980s uh into the early
1990s uh CBM became the the Secretariat
for
negotiations and then my sadness is that
I've learned that business uh operates
as pragmatism if there's not a burning
platform then business loses its
interest uh the one thing where I think
we made a very big mistake is that we
saw the peace process for us the
Constitutional negotiations as the
achievement it wasn't the achievement it
was the
springboard and so what we have in our
country at this stage we've got one of
the most Progressive constitutions in
the world uh since 1994 we've had
peaceful negotiations every 5 years and
we've got an economy that hasn't been
transformed so so I think the key thing
here with the historic uh threshold that
that Colombia has crossed a message that
I would take out of my own country we
have lost 20 years of potential progress
because we transformed the political
system with uh great inputs from
business we went from a civil war to a
peace process and then then we took the
foot off the
pedal and business and government didn't
engage adequately to create a
socioeconomic structure which would be
able to support a very uh young
democracy but I have to end with one of
my big- time leadership quotes or
lessons and uh and both of both of you
have commented on it already Sylvia and
Anton
during this time um on the mass
Democratic movement side the anti aparte
movement there were some amazing leaders
Nelson Mandela everybody's heard of uh
he was one of several hundred uh on the
mass Democratic movement side and one of
the peak leaders was a woman called
Albertina culu and she embodied the
Spirit uh that I think got us through
that uh I was meeting with some of the
radical
right-wing um white
supremacists and they said they would
meet with me in secret and I went to
Albertina who was one of the the the
most influential leaders of the time
women in her late 60s early 70s at that
stage and I asked her should I meet with
this group of white supremacists they
like the Klux clan um literally they
tortured people to death because of they
simply Were A different race and uh I
asked her shall I meet with them and
this is one of the reasons we got
through our own process without any
hesitation she said to me but my son
you've got no choice you may hate what
they stand for but you may never hate
them it's only by loving them that we'll
get into the
future and and for me that's one of the
things that business and Society had to
do we had to be able to look past why we
didn't trust one another uh
unfortunately we've lost 20 years we now
need to rebuild some of those
relationships I don't know whether the
crisis is big enough I think it will be
but that would be a caution that I would
put to Colombia is don't lose the
momentum and you have to get into the
socioeconomic transformation as soon as
possible because democracy cannot
succeed without delivery I think that's
probably a joint thank
[Applause]
you so well I just wanted to talk after
Christo because we had the opportunity
to uh to uh exchange ideas yesterday and
I thought that you have a very
compelling ER story to tell about how
important is a to have a
like a a unified Vision among the the
business Community about H what is this
all about and I will and I want to take
the the first one of the first things
that Serio Haro said in his presentation
because I think that this is the key
point on what we have to work together
and and what the business community and
this H and hopefully this Council H
private Council on H
on sustainable peace will work more more
o more than in a a following the
implementation first of all we have to
have a common Vision a common vision of
what is this piece process about and and
that is what we are divided in Colombia
that is why we are so divided in
Colombia because we for many the peace
process is to defeat the farc is to end
the farc and that's it we have done that
for many years in Colombia we have
demobilized today more than 50,000
competant in Colombia but we haven't
changed conditions we have haven't
changed conditions in h in the periphery
of Colombia and about and when I talk
about conditions I'm not just talking
about economic conditions which are key
but these are political conditions and
yes as Antonio said institutional
conditions our institutions in those in
those areas simply don't work so yes we
need to have a common view h of what is
the task we have H before us and what is
that we and what is this peace H process
all about it is not about demobilizing
the far that is very important yes but
that is a tiny tiny part of of the of
the task we have before us so
um talking about H common visions and
and what are the problems we
have in our periphery and Ana Maria gave
us some very compelling ER very
compelling figures about about the
inequalities and the gaps we have in
those areas ER one of the one of the
critical issues that I think that we
have to uh to bring up a common vision
is about the development model I think
that there is no doubt
ER in Colombia and maybe ER maybe the
the the left movements in
Colombia yes they are against capitalism
and and yes that is that is that is true
that is true but I think that that most
of Colombians believe in private in the
importance of the private sector to
generate welfare and to H generate
employment and development for the
country I think that that this is I
think that that is bottom line and I
don't think that that is there is no
question about about a a free market and
and and freedom of a of a for the for
the business for the business sector but
what I think is that that the model that
the the how do you what what is the
purpose of gener generating um the
question is what is the purpose of of
generating a and and accumulating um
resources is how you distribute those
resources in wellbe well-being for the
people and how you do it in a in a
manner that is a that is a a that is
good for the environment so these are
this is nothing new this are that
contemporary H discussions that are
already a in in the in the world of the
of the
development discussions so but I think
that we really need to come to a a a
consensus within and and to and to open
a discussion within the companies and
within the private sector about how we
do business and how do we
distribute a the the the the earnings of
the of uh of of the business so er yes
it is important to follow the
implementation it is very important but
before that we really have to begin to
have a different a a a discussion an
internal discussion about uh about this
these issues and and really understand
why in these areas of Colombia it hasn't
been possible to do development more a
in a in a in
a in um um legal in a legal way so uh I
will I this is more a call for Action ER
and uh and I really and I'm really
really very happy that H for this
initiative of uh of the Council of the
private Council H I really think these
are baby
steps but needed baby steps at this at
this moment and I hope that this will be
a scenario to begin this this H this
discussion not only about what is uh we
are going to do H in the implementation
and the day-to-day implementation which
is key but also how what is the common
view we have for our country and for the
development of the peripherial areas in
in Colombia
[Applause]
just so I would like to respond to the
comments and then I'm going to open to
the for questions of the okay but I
would like you to to concentrate if
possible in the issue that brought about
soci economic transformation I his his
message was strong and was competing us
not losing 20 years because we didn't do
the social economic transformation that
the country requires we need to do
redistributive policies we need to
reduce inequalities we need to improve
the opportunities for all the people in
in Colombia
so
please go
ahead um sometimes you have to um take a
look at history and try to understand
where you are and the French and the BR
and the Germans fought for 300 years and
uh when the union was established in the
50s we really had two members it was
France and Germany uh now they're so um
interconnected that it's also impossible
will think about a rupture among them
and I think this the same case uh the
economic conditions and the if we able
to
establish um good institutional rural as
we were talking before um uh processes
on companies and people that break away
from the
cultural um Minds that also s was
talking about that the countryside is
bad is poor uh we don't want anything
about it people have bad memories and we
can build uh an intelligent
institutionality uh economic
institutionality and other institutional
around it and we up to that process uh
diligently um I'm sure in decade will
start seeing a difference or half a
decade but at least a decade will start
seeing a difference Colombia is the
third or fourth uh largest um uh
unconquered agriculture Frontier of the
world after Brazil
brail
um uh Ukraine and I think maybe uh some
other country um for the
50 for the 10 or n billion people going
to have in in 30 years um so a lot of uh
really a lot of food come out of
Colombia and we don't have the the
mentality and the proces and um to be
able to export to to take that land that
is available there and produce all that
food
and and and and help the process of of
reducing the the um the poverty in those
in those rural
areas um I
I by the way
farc will do
Politics on their on their traditional
socialist
ideas timochenko when they signed the
the the agreement in Cena
said we are not defeated we will
maintain our ideas so they will the
political platform will be socialism
populism so at the end of the
day even though the the all that you
have tried people have tried to create
it to oppose to capitalism is a is a
terrible fail uh socialism of 21st
century is a very pathetic disaster
uh even though we have to help to
demonstrate that liberal democracy works
better for people than any other
system and we know what to do we KN we
know what is to be done for a country to
achieve better economic indicators and
social
indicators the difficulty is do that in
a
democracy because we are plenty of
examples of achievements in countries
like China
Singapore but they do not apply to our
case we have a very imperfect democracy
but de democracy at the end of the day
so I think that uh that is the challenge
and uh in that order of ideas we need to
build a more effective State and
especially and this is contained in a
very interesting F
document conducted by Mar Victoria we
need to revew our political order the
model of decentralization in Colombia is
not working well because we haven't been
able to build local
capabilities and we always mention that
the peace is going to
be in the regions peace process have to
be work in the regions however if we do
not have local
capabilities we can have a lot of broken
promises and expectations cannot be
fulfilled we need to improve politics
that's very important we had a very good
example now we knew that we needed a tax
reform and we knew what kind of tax
reform we needed in order to close gaps
between poor and rich
people however what finally ended up
being the tax reform was pretty
different from what we wanted what's the
difference in
between democracy if you want to pull it
away discussion group of
interest uh you know the art of the
possible that's why I think that and
that might be some uh uh kind of a dream
I I think that we need pack in modern
democracies we need to have facts
because discussion is part of the
Democracy as Mill said but you need to
reach certain agreements on basic things
to nurture uh and push better say push
uh economic growth and and and social uh
welfare that's why I think this is a
good opportunity because if we are
demonstrate that we can build an
effective state that has the Monopoly of
Law and Order in these regions we could
copy maybe that scheme to the other part
of the state that are not working very
well beginning for with the
centralization uh uh scheme that we have
it's not working
well well I think they've said most of
of of the important things around this I
think that we cannot forget that we in
the private sector
need people to buy our things we need
need people to have money we need people
that move the economy we need people
that we can trust working with us we
need capabilities as Antonio say so the
private sector is the most interested in
that all the things of Economic
Development goes well because in a poor
country you will not do good business
and the other thing that is a very good
thing um you can do good business I I
think you can do good business but not
grow the way you want to grow and have
the competitiveness you want to have and
the other thing I was going to say is H
that more over what what what they just
said I think there is something missing
in Colombia which is very important and
I think that this week was like Mar
Victoria said baby steps on on that path
which is uh corruption which is a war
against corruption and if you have
corruption in the central government you
have a lot of corruption outside the
central government I think we have had
uh very good things that have go through
in in in the central government but as
all the problems outside the central we
have a lot of problems and a lot of
challenges that we have to deal a about
ethical Behavior both in the private
sector and the
government okay I don't know I would
open
question um so it it seems very crucial
for your companies to be to have a
position on the peace deal not only
because you are giant companies in
Colombia but because also you
manufacture your goods and have um
branches in parts of the country that
are not just its most urban areas and
I'm wondering how you think industri
such as the tech industry and startups
what technology which I understand is
becoming a very large part of Colombian
industry how those very Urban rooted
companies that don't necessarily have
reasons to um be involved in more rural
areas of the country how those
Industries can be motivated to um take
part in the imple implementation of the
peace
deal is there any other questions maybe
so we can collect a few and
then um I would just be interested to
hear a little bit about how the private
sector is going to address sort of the
issue of the JY coefficient um and
especially the issue of land being held
sort of by
43% the top 1% and see what the private
sector role would be in
that thank you very much for um for your
words and for sharing with us a lot of
very interesting uh opinions regarding
this I had a question regarding more the
implicit uh implications of having uh
let's say in the case of promas uh
people from the farc uh working there of
course uh not in terms of the
individuals but in terms of uh who they
are as a group because it seems to me
somewhat contradictory to have a member
of the farilla um a former member of the
farilla working in a private firm and
then um seeing how most of the proposals
that we've heard here are to include all
of these people into the economy uh when
they to some extent are opposed to how
the system works uh maybe know a little
bit more about how how this uh let's say
conflict of interest plays plays
about the last one I uh that is already
happen
uh in the reintegration agency uh we
have numbers of
people that had been uh through the
process even before the
aana uh some vioria is 50,000 people has
re
integrated so they're already working in
the in the the
system
uh I don't think that is the
solution uh because that could count for
you know you know uh yeah something like
that but is is the message to say uh we
can we can open our companies if you
want to if you want to do that the first
thing that we have to understand is what
do they want to
do what do they like to do they can they
want to live in the cities and you have
you know as many uh decisions of of
people you have so it's a matter of
giving them the capabilities to do what
they value at the end of the day you
know capabilities as freedom is the con
capability of Freedom uh but I want to
tell you that that we went to Avana and
we spent like five hours with them
caros and we talk about this we had a
very Frank
conversation we were a group of eight
entrepreneurs and we had a very open and
Frank and crud discussion with the
secretar
LA uh telling them you know what we
thought understanding that we were taken
uh you want to put a chance supporting
them even though it was not popular
because there are a lot of uh uh scars a
lot of pain a lot of suffering and not
too many people is willing to forgive so
we told them clearly we are here we
support this but you have to help us to
make this possible and we don't believe
in the Venezuelan model we don't believe
in this and I mean that was very
clear after we left abana we we thought
that they kind of understand what the
whole thing is all about and uh even if
they don't like they have to understand
that uh the the the the the
least the the system that that works
more is the is the market economy and
and is not in our case that they in our
solar energy project that they work for
us but that we join effort with them
they they're going to have like a
cooperativas or something like that how
cooperativas in they have to have a
collective associations so our companies
can have joint ventures with their
associations they still have that notion
of collective but uh and
I have to respect them I I would like to
where are you
from ttoo
um I just wanted to add that there are
two kind of people in the gitaa well
well a lot of C but but mostly two the
ones that are on top and are the
military leaders but the rest is a very
big army of people and many of those
people are not there because they
believe in this the thing they just were
there because many of them did not have
an option they were taken from their
families when they were just kids or
they didn't have work they didn't have
anything else to do and that was the
only economic option they had so it is
not necessarily that they believe in
other system they just believe in
earning something for their families and
my experience with the people that have
been working with itel is is really
marvelous I have to say that from all
the people that I've had I only have one
person who left and the others are the
best workers that you can find in the
service stations they are so thankful
and they are so committed because that
was the second opportunity they had in
their lives for really having a work for
their families so so we have to remember
that there are like two kind of people
inside yeah can can I ask your um get
your question J um this morning on MIT I
was um invited to a little Network or
Workshop of V virtual reality and uh
I've seen the process but um when you
try to think about to applying it um
maybe it's too complex but we're
thinking but we need Farms that are that
are much more productive what they
are um but just walking to a farm in
vory reality with the spec
specifications that you need to have
ideally or at least uh not ideally but
medor
terms um it's very different from being
talked about or or um being shown in
video because Farmers I mean you need to
touch need to see obvious not virtuity
doesn't touch but touch with your eyes
the the grass and how the Grass Grows
and the kind of cow and those those kind
of things um could be very interesting
for his Farmers um that's the reason I
went there the other reason is um you
all the
biotechnology that is coming out what is
the kind of cows that can um be sort of
designed for this areas um and how
cheaply can we reproduce them to give
them massively to these Farmers that
have land and uh unemployed Workforce
because they have the two things but
they don't have cow they don't have the
the know how they don't have the
the the grass they ha to have uh the far
the milking and uh those those just two
examples of things you could do and to
radically increase the productivity
radically in the sense that um what
happened in Macarena is that many of
these Farmers when because they didn't
have the purchase guarantee of the milk
uh they just didn't produce the milk but
most of the cases they double the
production in 6 months I mean this is
100 100% uh increaseing in productivity
in 6 months how many of us could do that
um really double papers produce double
papers in six months or um very hard but
with those other um inputs I'm sure the
the impact could be
gigantic I I don't want to forget your
question uh uh the Gen issue in Colombia
uh supposedly we have two two you know
two ways to close the genie uh tax and
social investment tax does nothing
nothing genie before tax engineer tax in
colia exactly the same so you're doing
nothing with tax which you should do at
least reduce I don't know according to
expert she's an expert five six points
and social investment which accounts for
12% of GDP only close two or three
points of
Genie why because it's not well
focalized it's been uh not not use
properly so we need to reform how we
focus the social investment we need and
this uh uh lead me to a sentence of agus
Dion is capitalism by far has a better
path than socialism but capitalism needs
to be domesticated the way to
domesticate it is through a progressive
tax reform which we don't have yet and
focusing social investment where is
required
uh the land something like I don't know
correct me two million three million of
hectares should are going to be awarded
to small farmers so that uh that's part
of the of the process and it's very
important because supposedly the origin
of the the conflict is is a land uh but
for for you the uh Spanish Spanish
speaking people I recommend you uh to
read the book of Professor
jalo in laas it's a very it's a
different View of the conflict and he uh
he reviews in the last 50 years what
political
options far hat it's very
interesting IDE in word you read it yeah
good you like it interesting May
different vision from the traditional
Vision that we receive okay may I add
something about the the genie and and
the land which was I think um that was
brought in um I'm sure there is a lot of
effort to be done in terms of land
distribution although that was of the
main points that came out uh with the no
uh on the referendum and that was the
things that would really cleared to be
specified and the things that were
changed uh but the question that was
asked to to S hadu and that people uh
people are saying there was we lived
about rumors the oldest 5 years
and people say well no this is really
going to be a a land reform worse in
Venezuela was it wasn't that way but it
was really cleared out that the land
light rights wouldn't be taken but the
other thing that happens with the the
performers is that uh even though the
productivity is high probably higher
than the big
farms uh for studies that I've seen
um they increase increase
should be much more higher much much
higher um I when I did my thesis um many
years ago about colan yeah many years
ago about 200 years ago um I interviewed
president jpo who um had done
the
yes um the Land Reform in the 60s and he
was also underlining that you do have
Landing F sure but if you don't do the
inputs on the land if you don't get the
credit if you don't need the know how if
you don't get the the inputs on on U on
ass on assistance on technical
assistance if you don't give the the the
seeds on the fertilizers you might as
well not do the Land Reform so it's um a
land reform without those things is a
car with only two wheels you need the
other four the other two four wheels the
other two wheels have a
car okay so we will end up here thank
you very much for a very
interesting panel we have many
challenges in Colombia as you see we are
just starting and thank you Professor
shapo for allowing us to discuss these
issues I think it's important for the
country to do it and it's important to
go out of the country to talk more more
frankly about it so we will have a
reception in the second floor you are
all
invited and feel free to come and thank
you very much
[Applause]
[Music]
again